thank you
[Music]
hey what is this place it's the Nexus of
the Multiverse kid now shut up because I
don't remember which potion to put in
this little cup oh yeah this is the one
what's happening to me
oh
are you okay
[Music]
I think so
are you from another dimension
well
it's a long story but I'll make it quick
all right let's do this one last time
my name's Peter Parker I was bitten by a
radioactive spider and for six years
I've been need one and only Spider-Man
well I was dead for five those years but
that's another story
I saved a bunch of people I fell in love
saved the city and then the world I even
joined a team you might have heard of
them
no not them
there was Captain America also we had
Hulk Thor Black Widow Scarlet Witch
Doctor Strange black panther Ant-Man
Falcon the Winter Soldier pigeon and uh
oh that guy with the bow and arrow and
I'll never forget my mentor Mr Stark
what else oh there's this big purple guy
his chin kind of looked like
huh
[Music]
who are these guys
[Music]
oh here we go
not again
who are you guys anyway I gotta say you
look just like me say my name and I
magically appeared
who's next
I'm gonna put some dirt in your eye
is this still part of the experiments
beware my tasty Hostess snacks
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I have no idea what I'm looking at I
can't tell if you're just playing me
clips from the spider-verse movie or not
no this is all generated with AI whoa
what no for real we have a whole video
on the corridor crew Channel where we
break down how we recreated the
spider-verse style with AI
is so crazy